what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today we're gonna watch from
spider warren
spider-man no way home how loki confirms
toby maguire and andrew garfield
variant i actually listened to uh i
forget the title of this video that he
did just over the weekend but he posed a
great
theory of speculation as to why sony
might actually
show toby mcguire and or andrew garfield
if they are in the movie we didn't do a
reaction to it and
like when i first heard that question i
was like no that's stupid no way they
would let
and then he brings up a solid
speculation point in that video about
why they might actually do it like oh
maybe now now that you're saying that
actually yeah that's a great point it is
i'm putting into warren's more like
theory breakdown videos as of late
anywho let's see what's in store
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
loki episode 3
is only a couple of days away where
we're expecting some pretty big reveals
loki has already given us plenty of
things to talk about including the
multiverse different variants
secret wars kang all very very exciting
subjects that i will be talking a lot
more about but today
i want to talk about how loki actually
sets up spider-man
no way home and how not only does it
give us more evidence of tobey maguire
spider-man showing up along with andrew
garfield spider-man but
it actually explains kind of how they're
going to show up
and of course not only is loki going to
affect no way home but it's also going
to affect multiverse of madness pretty
much the same way it affects spider-man
no way home so
this video really is about both but i'm
going to try to keep the focus on
spider-man
also my marvel cheer giveaway with and a
seat ends in
10 days so click the link in the
description you know you want one
now if you haven't seen loki episode 2 i
will be talking about spoilers
specifically around the different
variants of loki
and we are starting with the spoilers
now when we get out on the branch we're
not just
looking for a time criminal we're
looking for a loki
a variation of this guy a type we should
all be very familiar with because the
tva
has pruned a lot of these guys almost
more than any other variant
and no two are alike slight differences
in appearances
or not so slight different powers
although powers generally include
shape-shifting illusion projections
so in this very clear and very obvious
scene in loki we saw
different variants of loki the first
loki was a loki
as a frost giant which of course he
truly is the next one was a very sporty
loki and then we got
a hulk version of loki which even
confused him himself
his last run-in with the hulk wasn't
exactly pleasant but the bottom line of
the scene
and the main point of this is to show
that all loki's don't
exactly look alike they look relatively
similar
but not necessarily 100 the same sure
now there's actually so many different
variants of loki that mobius says there
are many different ones almost
more than any other variant and he
specifically says
no two are alike there are slight
differences in appearances
or not so slight differences in
appearances
now this answers a question that some
fans have been asking about spiderman no
way home
about toby and andrew showing up and
that is they don't look alike they're
not going to
actually be the same spider-man they're
going to be different
and the answer to that is actually both
yes and no
no they aren't the same because they are
indeed going to be from
another universe but yes they are they
are the same in the fact that they are
peter parker
and they are spider-man mobius even goes
on to say that the powers can also
differ
and this explains another key difference
in mcguire
shooters that's a good point yeah why
are spider-man
see all three of these is a good point
classic spider-man abilities except for
toby maguire spider-man
his spider-man actually produces organic
web
and he shoots them from his arm instead
of a web shooter
insert the sperm jokes no yes it's been
it's been a good long time
yeah that's a great solid point it has
me actually wondering now that if let's
say toby mcguire and andrew garfield are
in this movie will they have
so much fun with it where you'll
actually see different versions of
tom holland as spider-man oh
a variety of different looks and maybe
he'll do blackface
that's the spider-man he should be miles
in morales universe
to see sony and marvel make a terrible
decision
oh good you just made me laugh by how
stupid it is
yeah i can't really add that's just the
perfect outfit
perfect because there's gotta be there's
gotta be a racist spiderman out there
and he's the only one who's best friends
with jay jonah jake
we're contributing nothing real here all
right let's keep going
and these differences have just been
explained what it seems like they're
doing here in the loki series
is setting up the future to not have
that many questions or
confusion about what is happening in
loki they just watch the show
the multiverse which i'm about to get
into and they are establishing that not
every version of the character has to
look the same despite whatever character
it is
even loki has female versions of himself
so not only can the characters slightly
differ but they could be a completely
different gender and they can be
a completely different being as we saw
him as sort of a hulk
episode 2 set up different variations of
the same character
that look different so we can have
thousands of different loki who
are still loki but look different and
have different abilities much like we're
going to have three different spider-man
who look different but kind of have the
same abilities all
still spider-man this could also set up
a female peter parker which they could
do we haven't heard any rumors or news
about that i would probably rather see
jessica drew
or spider-gwen when i was gonna bring up
the multiverse anything
is possible and what happened in the
last episode of loki the multiverse went
into madness and loki escaped from the
tva
and followed the female loki so we know
that there's going to be a conversation
between the two of them because we've
seen it in
a trailer we don't know what they're
talking about but we can probably assume
that lady loki is going to
somewhat reveal her plan to our loki her
plan
is i want andrew garfield
that's toby mcguire to finally
i'm cross huge marvel fan and i really
want sam raimi back for a doctor strange
movie so i'm thinking
a multiverse madness could solve all our
problems
what the hell are you talking about it's
not about you it's about toby maguire
and
garfield that's what this whole show is
about getting to them i'm sure they'll
talk about something important
now with her setting the multiverse into
madness it of course sets up multiverse
of madness but it also sets up
spider-man no way home
now we're not really sure of what's
going to happen with this sacred
timeline in the loki series right now
the tba has been dispatched to try
and fix all of these different time
branches but we know that once the nexus
point crosses the red line
they can't go back they can't undo what
has happened and a branch
timeline has been created forever i'm
sure the tva is going to manage to erase
some of them before they hit the red
line but since we do have a movie called
multiverse of madness
and spider-man no way home is going to
deal with the multiverse as well
i'm sure not all of those different
branches are going to be deleted
in fact i'm not even sure if the tva is
still going to be left standing by the
end of the loki series
i'm definitely thinking that kang is
somewhat in charge of the tva right now
but we'll see how that plays out
i think it's really smart what marvel's
doing with their marketing of getting
audiences to pay
close attention before they gave any
details themselves
about what loki would be exploring
ultimately
they unveiled the title of dr strange
multiverse of madness they made that
official
first to kind of give you a heads up of
start looking out for this start paying
attention to this because
there's going to be some important
things to just lead into this so it's
neat to be like oh damn
loki's doing all this they're doing
they're like the prelude for
what the events will be in uh it's like
i know marvel generally does that but
for this
specific concept for worldwide audiences
to latch
onto i think it was really smart of them
to do that because a lot of times like
when we're hearing about the spider-man
news we're hearing about loki we go back
to multiverse of madness
we go back to specifically those words i
think it's really smart
how they they did that just kind of
dawned on me in this moment oh yeah well
and with the way that like their
character development and storytelling
has grown and changed with these shows
and stuff like that i feel like
two has their laying down of easter eggs
and setting up of things for the future
you know you can do that in a way that
is a lot more
subtle but still apparent and that you
know functions as something to kind of
improve the magic of the world you're
watching right now but also promising
what's to come
instead of you know some of the clunkier
stuff that we've seen in the just movies
but we know that the supposed focus of
our loki is to take down the timekeepers
to overthrow them
loki doesn't like the idea of somebody
else controlling his destiny he doesn't
like the idea of fate
even though ironically enough he was the
one that wanted to control everybody
because he said it's easier for them yet
the guy himself has a hard time being
controlled
so i guess it's not really easier but
he's gonna take down
the timekeepers anyways or at least he's
going to try and then lady loki clearly
has a plan to get rid of the tva
because although she is different and
seems to be quite superior
she is still loki which means she is
also going to struggle with
freedom with fate so by the end of the
loki series they think these two logies
might actually take down the tva
which means there could be thousands
millions
billions of different timelines created
because there's going to be
no organization or timekeepers or
anything to stop the timelines from
being created or erase them when they
are
created and this is how we're going to
get spider-man no way home this is how
we're going to get the different
variants of our peter parker marvel is
kind of putting this right in front of
our eyes here
setting up toby and andrew to appear in
no way home the multiverse will be in
madness and these are just going to be
different variants of peter parker
and then supposedly we're going to be
seeing a lot of different variants of a
lot of different characters and doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
one rumor that i've heard that i
personally really
really really hope is true is that we're
going to be getting different
versions or variations we'll say now of
captain america
of iron man a black widow a bunch of
different characters played by
actors who could have played them for
example john krasinski could show up as
a variant of captain america tom cruise
could show up as a variant of iron man
emily blunt a variant i think this would
be pretty cool to see since those
characters could have played those roles
that was a possibility at one point in
time and if we kind of want to try and
speak somewhat realistically if the
multiverse was real there is a reality
that exists where they actually got
those roles
i would love that if tom cruise did it
because if he was to do iron man
and then he also did this with austin
powers gold member
how grand would it be tom cruise would
be the alternate reality version
of so many iconic characters it's
perfect
and then you can make a like a side
movie that takes place in the universe
where everyone is tom cruise
yeah and then of course i am always
crossing my fingers that we could dip
into the timeline or the different
universe or multiverse where the fox
universe lies and we could see
characters like
hugh jackman's wolverine patrick
stewart's professor x
and ian mckellen's magneto after all
patrick stewart himself confirmed that
he met with
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios to talk about some future
endeavors but we do know that patrick
stewart said he's done with professor x
so
we know he's not really returning as
professor x but
in multiverse objectives to do a quick
cameo that's not really him returning
that's not undoing his death from logan
it's just a quick little fun cameo so
i'm crossing my fingers for that
although it's not confirmed at all so
don't act like it is but this is how
loki sets up no way home in multiverse
of madness and they're doing it right in
front of our eyes they're starting to
set it up to where everything is going
to make sense when we eventually get to
no way home we won't have a lot of
questions it won't be that confusing
because they're going to get rid of all
of that confusion
right now in loki different variants are
established and the multiverse will be
established as well
and spider-man far from home will make
complete sense but go ahead and let me
know what you think about this
in the comments no way home don't forget
to like this video
there's a lot of youtubers have been
doing it no way far from home
coming and uh yeah if loki is indeed
doing all this setup so that way we
don't have as many questions that's
clever too because doing all this in a
show which is six to seven hours long
and run time depending on episode length
or whatever yeah you can easily
explain all this without getting bogged
down in exposition so much where it
detracts from the emotional experience
whereas spider-man no way home with
all the rumors that we've been hearing
about what's going to be included one of
the concerns that might be over
convoluted not just with characters but
also having to explain what's going on
so if you already have a property that's
really explaining what's going
on where audiences will get many months
to dive into this property so that way
it could all just be clear for them all
right yeah
that eliminates one worry where you just
gotta do like a simple recap
and uh no way home that way you're not
like overly confused as to what's really
going on so i like that man this is all
good stuff
yeah cause i i think you're i think if
they are in the movie yeah you're 100
right like this
loki is setting you up for the whole
variant explanation
for it yeah hondo placento i completely
agree with you guys subscribe to warren
if you haven't done so already he's been
killing it lately and
personally really enjoy these kinds of
videos i've been more i know like a lot
of times
like leaks and whatever but these
explanation videos are theories
i'm a big fan of subscribe to the real
rejects click the notification bell hit
the like button
follow john john humphrey on twitter and
instagram because i never tell you guys
to do that
catch you guys soon
you